you have an awesome connection with your
fans yeah I mean and I actually love
that about you know I think that's why
you're successful and what is like maybe
your most fun or coolest kind of fan
encounter I mean there's so many I
really do genuinely love my fans so much
I mean when you come from the digital
space you really understand that there's
no record label there was no one that
started except for people just
supporting you online so those
supporters are really responsible for a
lot of what I have and so I have so much
love for them but one of the most
meaningful stories I think you know
earlier this year when I came out online
I remember I was being I was really
scared and it was before I had a trip to
India and you know Indian culture is
quite taboo when it comes to sexuality I
was so stressed going to India and I was
like oh what are people gonna think I
don't know and I had a meet and greet
and I met with 200 fans and honestly I'd
say but a hundred fans came out to me to
my face during that meeting great and
for me that was so powerful because one
I know how hard that is and I was like
wow my new identity for you I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this